so the first film the carwash film was
there any plans to sell that or you
realize this is a film that's going to
be sort of my calling card yes I I never
thought at the very beginning of films i
was making us things that were going to
be sold i think that a lot of filmmakers
now when they make their short to make
their web series or whatever is there
making to kind of break into the film
business they always have an eye towards
monetizing it and i'm not saying you
don't need to monetize your work
everybody needs to pay your bills I like
living comfortably I'm sure a lot of
other people do too but I think when
you're starting out you've got to find
other ways to monetize your life so you
can advance your career because if at
the onset you're thinking about films
like the car wash or followed or some of
my earlier work if you add that as an
eye towards monetization you may not get
anyone watching it because no one knows
who you are you don't have a track
record you don't have any press you
don't have any authority to start
charging people for your work because
you're starting out your beginning just
like if you were going to a nine-to-five
job and you were stepping in the office
and an entry-level position that's what
you are as a starting filmmaker at an
entry-level position and so if you give
away your work like the car wash or like
followed all those different things then
you give the yourself the opportunity to
get as many eyeballs as possible it's a
lot easier with the internet and social
media these days and that used to be so
that people watch it hopefully people
write about it people talk about it and
share it so then hopefully it might get
in the hands of the right person or the
right press outlet that will help you to
make your next project but I think that
if you worry about monetization at the
onset as I did not with the car wash
then you're going to start putting
roadblocks into your career at an age
where you shouldn't be so let's take
some of those classmates that you may
have known back at Georgia Southern who
wanted to from the onslaught maybe
sounds like and you know don't see why
not but make this half-a-million-dollar
feature film
out of the gate somehow you knew that
you know I need to take smaller chunks
to do this where there are others that
you saw try to just jump off that diving
board and what happened sure I mean I've
seen many filmmakers in my career well
one of the things that you see as a
filmmaker I think and and this is
actually one of the hardest things I
think you have to swallow is when you
start as a filmmaker there's a lot of
people that want to do it everybody
wants to work in film everybody wants to
work independently and say hey I don't
go to nine to five job every day I write
all day or I a film all day or I edit
all day and as you get older and as you
get more experience slowly the people
you started with some of them start
peeling off some of them disappear from
the business entirely and then
eventually there's only a handful of you
that started that start at the same
point and I think that what separates
people is the fact that you have to take
those tiny steps and not those big leaps
if you try to make a feature film before
you've made a series of shorts or
documentaries or whatever it is you may
not have the storytelling capacity to
make a feature film because a feature
film is a much different ball game than
making a short you can make a really
effective short film but if you don't
understand the progression and logistics
of character development of narrative
arcs of shooting out of order to put
something back in order and make sense
dramatically that's a difficult task and
I think if you just start out doing that
not to say that there aren't examples of
people that have done that effectively
and successfully I think for the vast
majority of folks including some people
i started with they didn't have that
capacity and thus they didn't get
attention and weren't able to make their
second project
you